(a(applaudissements)
- - Le Québec, depuis
lala Révolution tranquille,
pependant 40 ans, s'est programé
enen fonction d'un très grand
obobjectif : celui de devenir
unune société politiquement
sosouveraine avec des projets
lilibéraux, progressistes,
ququi allaient faire de notre
sosociété quelque chose de bien,
ququelque chose décent, et qui
nonous inspirerait de la fierté.
EtEt tout cela a été détruit par
leles deux échecs référendaires.
NoNous vivons les débris
dede la défaite que nous nous
sosommes infligés nous-mêmes,
enen plus, c'est encore pire,
c'c'est encore pire!
- - Donc les deux défaites
réréférendaires ont eu
dedes conséquences considérables
susur, justement je dirais, la
trtransformation du nationalism.
-(-(en choeur): On veut un pays!
L Le nationalisme québécois
a a beaucoup évolué depuis
unun demi-siècle. On en suit
lala trajectoire dans
lele documentaire "La bataille
popour l'âme du Québec"
dede Francine Pelletier.
IlIl sera présenté sur nos ondes
dedemain.
JeJe reçois la réalisatrice et n
prprotagoniste à qui on fait
poporter le rôle de ce
nanationaliste identitaire.
PoPourquoi ce documentaire?
EsEst-ce que ce documentaire à ?
- - Il y a une longue évolution,
jeje n'ai pas le temps de vous
raraconter toutes les péripéties
etet commencer parti d'une chose
popour aboutir à cela, mais je
trtrouve que c'est un sujet
ababsolument impmportant et j'ai
momoi-même découvert plein de
chchoses en faisant t le
dodocumentaire, dont notamment a
blblessure que j'avais moi-même
sosous-estimé par rapport aux
écéchecs référendaires.
C'C'est vraiment là que moi un
chchoc consentant là-dessus, c't
ququ'à partir du dernier
réréférendum que la mentalité
d'd'assiégés, le fait d'être
obobligé de se sentir un peu pls
vuvulnérable, on allait vers
ququelque chose de grand, on est
totout d'un coup réduit à un étt
dede province et c'est la nature
huhumaine de vouloir se protéger
etet de se tenir.
- - Dans les deux référendums on
sese dit non à nous-mêmes et on
rereprend la déclaration de
MoMonsieur de Parizeau avec les
vovotes ethniques il y a toutes
sosortes de transitions vers un
nanationalisme plus identitaire.
- - Ce qui s'est passé autour du
réréférendum de 95, un peu avant
pepeu après, c'est une espèce de
susurgissement de mauvaise
coconscience.
LeLes Québécois francophones
nanationalistes se sont demandés
sisi le projet était légitime.
OnOn leur disait qu'ils étaientn
pepeu réfractaires au droit des
miminorités et ont rappelé la
trtriste mémoire et les discours
d'd'Henri Bourassa et tout le
rereste et les Québécois ont fii
papar intégrer une mauvaise
coconvention en montrer qu'il
vovoulait une patte blanche et e
c'c'est un débat démocratique.
DaDans cette opération on peut
didire que le pendule est allé n
pepeu loin, c'est-à-dire qu'on a
dédésincarné ce projet
cocomplètement.
AÀ force de le dire civique et
ououvert, il avait perdu son
cecentre de gravité c'est-à-dire
ququ'il n'a pas de sens sans
l'l'existence d'une majorité
hihistorique francophone.
CeCette majorité ne parvenait ps
àà dire "nous"et c'était très
paparadoxal, il fallait au fond
raravivé cela.
- - Certains disent que le nous
esest identitaire, et même danse
fifilm on dit que c'est xénopho.
- - Par le nous, mais au momente
lala crise des accommodements
raraisonnables, il y a vraimentn
jejeu de dominos.
IlIl y a l'échec référendaire et
cece que Jacques dit, cette
mementalité d'incriminer, on
dedevient plus diversifié il y a
lele mouvement contraire dans ls
ununiversités où on commence à
reregarder le passé, ce qu'on
n'n'avait pas fait depuis la
rérévolution tranquille et ensue
lala crise des accommodements
raraisonnables vient bâtir là-
dedessus est un moment clé où on
paparle qu'il faut garder
cecertaines personnes, il faut s
cocontrôler.
L'L'avait jamais vu cela, c'estn
chchangement radical et pour la
prpremière fois le nationalismee
n'n'est plus un projet
d'd'autonomie, ce n'est plus un
prprojet qu'on conjugue avec le
féfédéral, ça devient la laïcit.
AlAlors il y a vraiment quelque
chchose qui bascula à ce momentà
etet ça continue jusqu'à
auaujourd'hui.
- - Dans le film envoie Mme Mars
ququi présente sa loi sur la
lalaïcité quand il reviendra auu
popouvoir elle présentera la
chcharte des valeurs et elle fat
dedes discours où elle dit nous,
elelle ne veut plus Riel et
ininclusif, mais ça ne convainc
papas?
- - C'est très malheureux parce
quque le nous de Pauline Maroist
dede toute cette mouvance
popolitique autour d'elle c'état
nonous les Québécois, ce n'était
papas les Canadiens français,
c'c'était les Québécois, tout le
QuQuébec dont le coeur est formé
papar la majorité historique
frfrancophone.
ToToutes les composantes de la
sosociété québécoise qui forme e
pepeuple québécois.
OnOn a beaucoup imputé à nous ds
vevelléités de fermeture, de rei
susur le monde Canadiens franças
etet d'e'exclusion aussi, alorse
ququ'il s'agissait d'une façon e
nonommer le peuple québécois sas
ococculter sa composante
mamajoritaire.
C'C'était ça l'idée, mais ça n'a
papas été reçu?
- - On a un extrait de Monsieur
LeLegault, qui est dans le film,
auau moment de déposer la loi sr
lala laïcité.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Bien, on n'est pas
sosouverainistes, là, donc
onon ne veut pas faire de
réréférendum sur la souverainet,
mamais on veut défendre nos
vavaleurs, défendre notre langu.
EtEt, oui, on est nationalistes.
MoMoi, je pense que la position
ququ'on a prise et sur la laïci,
enen interdisant les signes
rereligieux pour les personnes
enen autorité, et sur la défense
dede notre langue, le français,
çaça relie une majorité
dede Québécois. Donc, je pense
ququ'on soit à Québec ou
ququ'on soit au fédérale,
onon devrait écouter la majorité
dedes Québécois.
- - Au Québec, ça fait longtemps
ququ'on a décidé de séparer
lala religion et l'État. Et,
çaça fait plus de 10 ans qu'on
dédébat des signes religieux.
IlIl est temps de fixer des règs
paparce qu'au Québec, c'est come
çaça qu'on vit.
- - Concrètement, elle a changé
ququoi la loi 21? J'ai
l'l'impression qu'il y a eu
bebeaucoup de division dans
leles 20 dernières années, puis
ququ'il fallait faire quelque
chchose, mais que les choses
ququi ont été faites étaient
tetellement superficielles.
C'C'étaient comme des paillettes
popour dire : "Et voilà! On a ft
ququelque chose!" Alors qu'au
fifinal, ça a des effets concres
susur des groupes marginalisés
etet ça n'apporte rien au groupe
dodominant, ça apporte rien
àà la majorité des Québécois
àà part le sentiment de dominer.
- - Juste cette semaine Ottawa t
ququ'il va aller à la cour supre
cocontre la loi 21 et de la clae
dédérogatoire qui permettait au
gogouvernement permettait de de
seses préventives donc si on est
faface à un blocage qui arrive?
- - Cet extrait veut dire que
c'c'est ça qui arrive avec le
dadanger du nous, c'est qu'il
n'n'est pas interprété comme
ququelque chose de collectif, il
esest quelque chose, et la CAQ t
dedevenu maître dans là-dedans,
dedes gestes pour préserver la
mamajorité francophone et les gs
dede la minorité ne se sentent s
ininclus et ça ne règle pas le
prproblème des signes religieux
pupuisqu'il n'y en avait pas.
- - Quand François Legault dit
ququ'au Québec c'est comme cela
ququ'on vit, ce qu'il veut diree
quque tout le Québec dit comme
cecela est bien évidemment c'est
lala traduction d'une façon de
vivivre qui depuis longtemps est
cecelle de la majorité
frfrancocophone.
PoPourquoi avoir honte de dire e
chchose parereille?
- - On voit les derniers sondags
ququi montrent à quel point la Q
a a le soutien.. 53 % de la
mamajorité francophone se pourqi
unune majorité ne peut pas
s's'affirmer et invite et inclue
leles gens à parler la langue et
adapter des valeurs communes?
- - Encore faut-il avoir cette
ininclusion.
PaParler aux jeunes, qu'ils soit
mmême pas fils d'émigrants,
ququ'ils soient parfaitement
QuQuébécois, ils vont vous dire
auaussi que la culture qui les
inintéresse c'est la culture dea
didifférence.
LeLe problème de parler du nous
s's'il n'est pas conjugué au
plpluriel c'est qu'on se passe e
lala modernité, la modernité s't
lele métissage.
- - Le nom n'est pas fermé sur
lului-même, il n'est pas ethniqe
etet le port d'une composition
mamajoritaire et invite tous cex
ququi veulent se joindre à lui.
C'C'est un ou inclusif et serait
fefermée..
- - il y a une division.
- - La loi 21 est un affront
didirect aux femmes musulmanes.
- - C'est une façon de vivre
enensemble.
- - C'est pour cela qu'il faut
vovoir ce documentaire qui va
fafaire débat.
NoNous allons le voir sur Tou.t.
JaJacques Beau